foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones and
House of the dragon video in this video
we will be looking ahead at next week's
episode as you all know HBO released
their official video after last night's
episode so let's have a look at what's
going to be happening once we jump
forward a full decade in this show the
new video begins with us getting an
update on the latest developments and
the stepstones after defeating the crab
feeder then leaving the region Damon has
left the stepstones undefended resulting
in the islands growing unstable once
again now that we've jumped forward a
full decade in this story renera and
Allison now sit on visery sargaryen
small Council it's actually Alison who
brings up the fact that Damon has left
the stepstones undefended however renera
does remind her that they're the ones
who are actually left vulnerable this is
to show us how renera and Allison are at
odds with one another moving forward
from here on out we most likely won't
see them align with one another ever
again unfortunately the days of their
loving friendship are now over we then
see the younger version of aemon
Targaryen the second born son of Osiris
Saint Alison in this scene he's shown
looking for a dragon of his own now as
you all know he will not be able to walk
right up and mount any dragon the first
thing he will have to do is form a bond
with the dragon and I don't think he
will be mounting this Dragon shown here
someone else is actually flying on his
Dragon right now but I don't want to get
into that just yet in the following
scene we see viserys and Ellison's
firstborn son aegon as he's fighting
with raniera's son in the yard notice in
this scene how aegon is wearing the
green under his armor rather than the
black and red of House Targaryen this
goes to show Allison's influence over
her son this is very reminiscent of
Joffrey from Game of Thrones as you all
know although Joffrey was led to believe
his father was King Robert Baratheon he
was mostly shown wearing the red and
gold of his mother's house Lannister it
just goes to show you who they really
favor in these situations we can now
assume that aegon will follow his
mother's lead now if you also notice in
this scene renyra's son has very dark
hair you should find this interesting
because renera and her new husband Elena
or valerion have the white blonde hair
once again like Cersei and her children
in Game of Thrones this will lead many
to believe that rhaenyra's sons are not
legitimate this is a major issue because
her sons are her heirs set to inherit
the Iron Throne now notice how this man
standing right here by the boys has a
frustrating look on his face as aegon is
kicking some ass that man is Sir Harwin
strong the alleged father of rhaenyra's
sons as you all know rhaenyra is now
married to sirleen or valerion but as we
saw in the last episode they did make a
deal that they could still find their
own lovers outside of the marriage well
many suspect that rhaenyra's dark-haired
sons are actually fathered by Harwin who
is standing here looking angry as his
son is losing the fight unfortunately
rhaenera and Allison's growing hatred
for each other will fall onto their sons
as well Alison's Sons will grow to hate
raniero's Sons because they believe they
are stealing their Birthright what makes
it even worse is the fact that raniera's
Sons might not even be legitimate
therefore aegon in amon's Birthright is
being stolen by bastards who as we all
know are always seen as a stain on the
family's name now if someone were to
find out or even assume her sons are not
legitimate well you can imagine they
will want to stop them from ascending
the Iron Throne this will be one of the
major focuses throughout the next
episode we also hear Alison say you will
be king as we see a much older aegon
standing here once again this shows
serato's advice did affect his daughter
she will now see that her own son
ascends the Iron Throne regardless if
Rainer does remain as her father's Heir
we also see viserys has aged
considerably and I'm actually shocked
he's still alive a full decade later
after the last episode the man has been
disintegrating for years and as you can
all imagine he will not be around for
much longer as soon as he is gone he
will no longer be around to hold
everything together not that he really
was but it did at least stop blood from
getting shed so soon now in the
following scene we see Lady Lena
valerion the eldest and only daughter of
Lord Corliss valerion and rhaenys
Targaryen in the the last episode during
the wedding we saw Daemon getting to
know her a little bit better on the
dance floor in George R Martin's Fire
and Blood Damon made lady late on
Valeria on his second wife I'm assuming
they've done the same here as you can
see in this shot lady Elena and Damon
also now have daughters of their own
named Rayna and Bella Targaryen we can
also see Lady Lena is holding her belly
therefore we know she's due to have
another one very soon we also see one of
their daughters grab one of the dragon
eggs from the fire they might be getting
the egg ready to set inside of the new
baby's bed in hopes of them forming an
immediate bond with the dragon we then
see Damon and his wife flying side by
side on their dragons caraxis and vegar
now I'm hoping we actually find out how
Lady Lena mounted Veigar as you all know
vegar has been absent from the show so
far somehow lady Elena valerion mounted
the largest dragon in Westeros and we're
not really sure how or where she did it
I am interested in learning more about
that event although they may never
actually go into it we then get another
new glimpse of a very small Dragon
inside of the Dragon pit in King's
Landing I believe this is a scene
involving rhaenyra's sons and it almost
looks as if they're allowing her sons to
go find their own dragon for those of
you who don't know all three arenara's
sons from her first marriage will be
Dragon Riders during the dance of the
Dragons jakari's valerion will ride the
dragon for Max Luke Harry's valerion
will ride the dragonrx and her son
Joffrey will ride on the dragon tyraxis
this scene might show us how they
mounted each of their dragons we then
hear Alison and viserys discussing
rhaenyra's Sons Allison says to have one
child like that is a mistake but to have
three like that is an insult she is
referring to all three arenara's sons
being bastards who are not worthy for
the Iron Throne we even hear the new
hand of the king say everyone has eyes
and I believe he's saying that the
Harwin the alleged father he's most
likely warning him about what will
happen if everyone does find out they're
his sons he very well could be executed
for this given the fact that the father
is her Harwin the seed is strong takes
on a whole new meaning once again
rhaenyra is setting herself up for
failure it's almost as if she wants to
start a damn War now I had a very good
feeling this show would get better and
better with each episode and it
certainly looks like they've done that
here literally everything is falling
apart everyone is already deciding on
which side they will stand once viserys
is gone where now only what feels like
moments away from seeing the dance of
the Dragons officially begin the once
great House of Targaryen will have an
incredible Fall From Grace let's just
hope someone is still standing after all
the dust settles because many lives as
well as dragons will be lost to
Bloodshed well my friends get ready
because it looks like the Game of
Thrones has only begun let me know what
all of you think down below as always I
have to thank all of you for watching
another one of my videos I have several
more videos releasing in the following
days so I hope I'll see all of you back
here for those also have a great day
everyone I'll see you soon bye
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]